How do you explain when things don't go
as we assume?
Or better, how do you explain when others are able to achieve things
that seem to defy all of the assumptions?
For example
why is Apple so innovative?
Year after year, after year, after year
they're more innovative than
all their competition.
And yet they're just a computer company.
They're just like everyone else.
They have the same access to
the same talent,
the same agencies,
the same consultants, the same media.
Then why is it that they seem to
have something different?
Why is it that Martin Luther King
led the civil rights movement?
He wasn't the only man who suffered
in a pre-civil rights America
and he certainly wasn't the only great orator of the day.
Why him?
And why is it
that the Wright brothers
were able to figure out control-powered man flight
when there were certainly other teams
who were better qualified,
better funded
and they didn't achieve powered-man flight.
The Wright brothers beat them to it.
There's something else at play here.
About three and a half years ago
I made a discovery
and this discovery profoundly changed my view on how I thought the world worked
and it even profoundly changed the way in which I operate in it.
As it turns out
there's a pattern.
all the great and inspiring leaders and organizations in the world
whether it's Apple or Martin Luther King
or the Wright brothers
they all think, act, and communicate
the exact same way
and it's the complete opposite to everyone else.
All I did was codify it
and it's probably the world's simplest idea.
I call it The Golden Circle.
WHY, HOW, WHAT.
This little idea explains
why some organizations and some leaders
are able to inspire
where others aren't.
Let me define the terms really quickly.
Every single person,
every single organization on the planet
knows what they do 100 percent.
Some know how they do it
whether you call it your differentiating value proposition
or your proprietary process
or your USP
but very very few people or organizations
know why they do what they do.
And by why I don't mean to make a profit.
That's a result. It's always a result.
By why I mean
what's your purpose, what's your cause,
what's your belief?
Why does your organization exist?
Why do you get out of bed in the morning
and why should anyone care?
Well as a result
the way we think, the way we act,
the way we communicate
is from the outside in.
It's obvious we go
from the clearest thing to the fuzziest thing.
But the inspired leaders in the
inspired organizations
regardless of their size,
regardless of their industry
all think, act, and communicate
from the inside out.
Let me give you an example.
I use Apple because they're easy to understand and everybody gets it.
If Apple were like everyone else
a marketing message from them might
sound like this we make great computers
they're beautifully designed simple to
use and user friendly wanna buy one and
that's how most of us communicate that's
how most marketing is done that's how
most sales done and that's how most of
us communicate interpersonally we say
what we do we say how we're different or
how we better and we expect some sort of
behavior a purchase a vote something
like that here's our new law firm we
have the best lawyers with the biggest
clients we have you know we always
perform for our clients do business with
us here's our new car it gets great gas
mileage it has you know leather seats by
our car but it's uninspiring here's how
Apple actually communicates
everything we do we believe in
challenging the status quo we believe in
thinking differently the way we
challenge the status quo is by making
our products beautifully designed simple
to use and user friendly we just happen
to make great computers wanna buy one
totally different right you ready to buy
a computer from me all I did was reverse
the order of the information what it
proves to us is that people don't buy
what you do people buy why you do it
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it
this explains why every single person in
this room is perfectly comfortable
buying a computer from Apple but we're
also perfectly comfortable buying an mp3
player from Apple or a phone from Apple
or a DVR from Apple but as I said before
Apple's just a computer company there's
nothing that distinguishes them
structurally very many of their
competitors their competitors are all
equally qualified to make all of these
products in fact they tried a few years
ago gateway came out with flat-screen
TVs they're eminently qualified to make
flat-screen tvs they've been making some
flat-screen monitors for years nobody
bought one Dell came out with mp3
players and PDAs and they make great
quality products and they can make
perfectly well design products and
nobody bought one in fact talking about
it now we can't even imagine buying an
mp3 player from Dell why would you buy
an mp3 player from a computer company
but we do it every day people don't buy
what you do they buy why you do it the
goal is not to do business with anybody
with everybody who needs what you have
the goal is to do business with people
who believe what you believe
here's the best part none of what I'm
telling you is my opinion it's all
grounded in the tenets of biology not
psychology biology if you look at a
cross-section of the human brain looking
from the top down what you see is the
human brain is actually broken into
three major components that karley
perfectly with the golden circle our
newest brain our Homo Sapien brain our
neocortex corresponds with the what
level the neocortex is responsible for
all of our rational and analytical
and language the middle two sections
make up our limbic brains and our limbic
brains are responsible for all of our
feelings like trust and loyalty it's
also responsible for all human behavior
all decision-making and it has no
capacity for language in other words
when we communicate from the outside in
yes people can understand vast amounts
of complicated information like features
and benefits and facts and figures
it just doesn't drive behavior when we
communicate from the inside out we're
talking directly to the part of the
brain that controls behavior and then we
allow people to rationalize it with the
tangible things we say and do this is
where gut decisions come from you know
sometimes you can give somebody all the
facts and your figures in these I know
what all the facts in detail say but it
just doesn't feel right why would we use
that verb it doesn't feel right
because the part of the brain that
controls decision-making doesn't control
language and the best we can muster up
is I don't know it just doesn't feel
right or sometimes you say you're
leading with your heart or you're
leading with your soul well I hate to
break it to you there's onde other body
parts controlling your behavior it's all
happening here in your limbic brain the
part of the brain that controls
decision-making and not language but if
you don't know why you do what you do
and people respond to why you do what
you do then how will anybody how will
you ever get people to vote for you or
buy something from you or more
importantly be loyal and want to be a
part of what it is what you bet you do
again the goal is not just as to sell
people who need what you have the goal
is to sell to people who believe what
you believe the goal is not just to hire
people who need a job it's to hire
people who believe what you believe I
always say that you know this if you if
you if you hire people just because they
can do a job they'll work for your money
but if you hire people who believe what
you believe they work for you with blood
and sweat and tears and no air nowhere
else is there a better example of this
than with the Wright brothers most
people don't know about Samuel Pierpont
Langley and back in the early 20th
century the pursuit of powered man
flight was like the dot-com of the day
everybody was trying it and Samuel
Pierpont Langley had what we assume to
be the recipe for success
I mean even now when you ask people why
did your product or why did your company
fail and people always give you the
permeate same permutation of the same
three things undercapitalized the wrong
people bad market conditions it's always
the same three things so let's explore
that Samuel Pierpont Langley was given
$50,000 by the War Department to figure
out this flying machine money was no
problem
he held a seat at Harvard and worked at
the Smithsonian and was extremely
well-connected he knew all the big minds
of the day he hired the best minds money
could find and the market conditions
were fantastic the New York Times
followed him around everywhere and
everyone was rooting for Langley and how
come we've never heard of Samuel
Pierpont Langley a few hundred miles
away in Dayton Ohio Orville and Wilbur
Wright they had none of what we consider
to be the recipe for success they had no
money they paid for their dream with the
proceeds from their bicycle shop not a
single person on the Wright brothers
team had a college education
not even Orville or Wilbur and the New
York Times followed them around nowhere
the difference was Orville and Wilbur
were driven by a caused by a purpose by
a belief they believed that if they
could figure out this flying machine
it'll change the course of the world
Samuel Pierpont Langley was different he
wanted to be rich and he want to be
famous he was in pursuit of the result
he was in pursuit of the riches and lo
and behold look what happened the people
who believed in the Wright brothers
dream worked with them with blood and
sweat and tears the others just worked
for the paycheck and they tell stories
of how every time the Wright brothers
went out they would have to take five
sets of parts because that's how many
times they would crash before they came
in for supper and eventually on December
17th 1903 the Wright brothers took
flight
and no one was there to even experience
it we found out about it a few days
later and further proof that Langley was
motivated by the wrong thing the day the
Wright brothers took flight he quit he
could have said that's an amazing
discovery guys and I will improve upon
your technology but he didn't he wasn't
first he didn't get rich he didn't get
famous so he quit people don't buy what
you do they buy why you do it and if you
talk about what you believe you will
attract those who believe what you
believe well why is it important to
believe something called the law of
diffusion of innovation and if you don't
know the law you definitely know the
terminology the first two and a half
percent of our population are our
innovators the next thirteen and a half
percent of our population are our early
adopters the next thirty four percent
are your early majority your late
majority and your laggards the only
reason these people by touch-tone phones
is because you can't fire rotary phones
anymore
we all sit at various places at various
times on the scale but the law of
diffusion of innovation tells us is that
if you want mass-market success or
mass-market acceptance of an idea you
cannot have it until you achieve this
tipping point between 15 and 18 percent
market penetration and then the system
tips and I love asking businesses what's
your conversion on new business and they
love to tell you oh it's about 10%
proudly well you can trip over 10% of
the customers we all have about 10% who
just get it that's how we describe them
right that's like that gut feeling oh
they just get it the problem is how do
you find the ones that just get it
before you're doing business with them
versus the ones who don't get it
so it's this here this little gap that
you have to close as Jeffrey Moore calls
it crossing the chasm because you see
the early majority will not try
something until someone else has tried
it first and these guys the innovators
in the early adopters they're
comfortable making those gut decisions
they're more comfortable making those
intuitive decisions that are driven by
what they believe about the world and
not just what product is available these
are the people who stood on line for six
hours to buy an iPhone when they first
came out when you could have just walked
into the store the next week and bought
one off the shelf these are the people
who spent $40,000 on flat-screen TVs
when they first came out even though the
technology was substandard and by the
way they didn't do it because the
technology was so great they did it for
themselves it's because they wanted to
be first people don't buy what you do
they buy why you do it and what you do
simply proves what you believe in fact
people will do the things that prove
what they believe the reason that person
bought the iPhone on the first in the
first six hours of stood and sit in line
for six hours was because what they
believed about the world and how they
wanted everybody at see them they were
first people don't buy what you do they
buy why you do it so let me give you a
famous example of famous failure and a
famous success of the law of diffusion
of innovation first the famous failure
it's a commercial example as we said
before a second ago the recipe for
success is money in the right people in
the right market
Editions right you should have success
then look at TiVo from the time TiVo
came out about eight or nine years ago
to this current day they are the single
highest quality product on the market
hands down there is no dispute they were
extremely well-funded market conditions
were fantastic I mean we use TiVo as a
verb like TiVo stuff on my piece of junk
time or in a DVR all the time but TiVo
is commercial failure they've never made
money and when they went IPO their stock
was at about 30 or 40 dollars then
plummeted and it's never traded above
ten in fact I don't thinks it's even
traded above six except for a couple of
little spikes because you see when TiVo
launched their product they told us all
what they had they said we have a
product that pauses live TV skips
commercials rewinds live TV and
memorizes your viewing habits without
you even asking and the cynical majority
said we don't believe you we don't need
it we don't like it you're scaring us
what if they had said if you're the kind
of person who likes to have total
control over every aspect of your life
boy do we have a product for you it
pauses live TV skips commercials
memorizes your viewing habits etc etc
people don't buy what you do they buy
why you do it and what you do simply
serves as the proof of what you believe
now let me give you a successful example
of the law of diffusion of innovation in
the summer of 1963 250,000 people showed
up on the mall in Washington to hear dr.
King speak they sent out no invitations
and there was no website to check the
date how do you do that
well dr. King wasn't the only man in
America who was the who was a great
orator he wasn't the only man in America
who suffered in a pre-civil Rights
America in fact some of his ideas were
bad but he had a gift he didn't go
around telling people what needed to
change in America you know he went
around and told people what he believed
I believe I believe I believe he told
people and people who believe what he
believed took his cause and they made it
their own and they told people and some
of those people created structures to
get the word out to even more people and
lo and behold 250,000 people showed up
on the right day on the right time to
hear him speak how many of them showed
up for him
zero they showed up for themselves it's
what they believed about America that
got them to travel on a bus for eight
hours to stand in the Sun in Washington
for in the middle of August it's what
they believed and it wasn't about black
versus white 25 percent of the audience
was white dr. King believed that there
were two types of laws in this world
those that are made by a higher
authority Authority and those that are
made by man and not until all the laws
that are made by man are consistent with
the laws that are made by the higher
thought he will we live in a just world
it just so happens that the civil rights
movement was the perfect thing to help
him bring his cause to life we followed
him not for him but for ourselves and by
the way he gave the I have a dream
speech not the I have a planned speech
listen to politicians now with the
comprehensive 12-point plans are not
inspiring anybody because there were
leaders and there are those who lead
leaders hold a position of power or
authority but those who lead inspire us
whether they're individuals or
organizations we follow those who lead
not because we have to but because we
want to we follow those who lead not for
them but for ourselves and it's those
who start with Y that have the ability
to inspire those around them or find
others who inspire them thank you very
much
Sharon
that's video on the human Network Cisco
welcome to the human network